[Music]
good evening it's good to see everyone
again tonight we're gonna be going on a
little bit farther and the name of our
message is Ichabod the glory has
departed I want to give a quick overview
of why the title it comes from First
Samuel chapter 4 verse 19 through 22 and
I'm going to just do this in a very
abbreviated way what had happened is the
children of Israel were there in the
land of Canaan and their arch enemy the
Philistines had attacked and the high
priest Eli his two sons were priests but
they were not god-fearing men and Israel
knew that whenever they went into battle
for them to win they had to take the
throne of God before them that's what
the Ark of the Covenant it is you have a
covering cherub on each side you have a
mercy seat it's the throne of God it was
a symbol of where he dwells and they
went into battle and they were not doing
well and to the best of my memory hophni
and Phinehas said we need the ark and
they did not have permission from God to
take the ark but they took it anyway and
they went into battle and because they
had taken the ark but did not have God's
blessing they were defeated terribly and
a messenger came running back to Eli and
when he got back to Eli he said we've
lost I mean
Israel has been defeated the ark or he
said your two sons have been killed and
the Ark of the Covenant has been taken
by the enemy when Eli heard that he fell
off of his chair and broke his neck and
died one of his two
sons wife was pregnant almost ready to
give birth and on the moment when the
delivery was about to happen she heard
this news and she cried out Ichabod
the glory has departed the glory of God
rested upon that Ark of the Covenant
what was underneath of the mercy seat
the law of God the law of God I want you
to make a note of that because we're
gonna talk about that tomorrow God's law
or the law of God if you can if you
could think about it in in a different
way it's not just something that belongs
to him
the word God in Greek is Theo's it means
deity and divinity and I know that's God
Almighty
but that's what the word we're just
looking at with the word means the law
the word in Hebrew is Torah it means
instructions
it doesn't mean commands simply it means
instructions with this computer I have
code in the computer when I buy the
computer brand-new it has laws code that
is written inside of it it says if I
press enter this is what the computer is
supposed to do if I press backspace or
escape this is what the computer is
supposed to do God's instructions are
like a code they're instructions in
righteousness and purity and holiness in
victory the law of God is the law of
what it takes to have the divine nature
that's why David said King David thy law
have I hid in my heart that I might not
sin against thee you
our instructions I have put inside of my
heart so when the law of God is no
longer being kept the glory of God is no
longer upon the throne if you remove the
Ten Commandments from the throne you
have a form of godliness but you have no
power does that make sense and she named
her child Ichabod and said the glorious
departed from Israel for the ark or the
throne of God has been taken
marvelous be beyond expression is the
blindness of the people of this
generation there are few who have any
just conception of the deceptive power
of spiritualism many people play with it
they think well I'm not gonna go that
far I'm just gonna I'm just gonna buy a
Ouija board or I'm just gonna bring this
movie home or I'm just gonna you know
bring this music home I'm not gonna go
that far
it only takes one bite few have any just
conception of the deceptive power of
spiritualism and the danger of coming
under its influence thousands reject the
Word of God as unworthy a belief and yet
with eager confidence they receive the
deceptions of Satan so fully have they
yielded to the tempter so closely
are they united with him and so
thoroughly are they imbued with his
spirit that they have no power and no
inclination to break away from his snare
do you remember in our last message we
talked about yoga about how it means to
be yoked to or join to in the very first
message or second one we talked about
how these Hollywood stars and musicians
had become joined to evil spirits they
had invited them into their lives and
sometimes people say well I'm not gonna
go that far yeah I'm just it's just a
little sin Ellen White says of Judas
when she talked about him the Bible says
Christ looked at the 12 disciples he
said have I not chosen you twelve and
yet one of you is a devil Ellen White
said the demons name was selfishness
that she named it and she listed a lot
of other names that are there spirits
are named
for what they do or for what their
character traits are that's what they do
selfishness cause Judas to lose eternity
not just his physical life says the
Prophet I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs words tongues and they are the
spirits of Devil's working miracles
which go forth unto the kings of the
earth and of the whole world for one
reason to gather them to the Battle of
that great day of God Almighty
you can read revelation 19 through 21
and it actually talks about the fact
that when Christ is returning the kings
of the earth and their armies will
gather themselves together to make war
with him that sitting on the horse and
I'm not going to take time to go into
this in depth but have you ever
considered something when Christ returns
the second time it's a physical event I
mean physically he really is traveling
all the way from heaven to here did you
know that astronomers will see him
coming before we do if they're looking
in outer space they can see a year ahead
of time when a comet's coming have you
ever considered that and do you know
that the number one the most expensive
and elaborate telescope array in the
entire world is owned by the Vatican and
the name of it used to be the Lucifer
project but they got so much flak and
controversy over it
that they changed it and they called it
Lucy it's an acronym now and they said
it means this but it was originally
called the Lucifer or Light Bearer
project they're watching outer space
because they're preparing for this event
except those listen to this except those
who are kept by the power of God through
faith in his word the whole world will
be swept into the ranks of this delusion
the people are fast being lulled into a
fatal security to be awakened only by
the outpouring of the wrath of God
as spiritualism more closely imitates
the nominal Christianity of the day it
has greater power to deceive and ensnare
Satan himself is converted after the
modern order of things he will appear in
the character of an angel of light you
see there on the left hand of the screen
a book by Peter Tyler called the return
to the mystical this is a book on
returning back to the Roman Catholic
desert fathers and the Mystics
on the far right you see another book
which I did not include the details on
because I don't want anybody to go would
try to purchase it it was called the
yoga of Jesus and they actually are
telling people that the miracles that
Jesus did anybody can do because Jesus
did this because he understood pantheism
and the Hindu practice of yoga in the
center there is a book and a series that
was released within the last twelve
years it's called A Course in Miracles
Oprah Winfrey was the one that promoted
this book in this series it was
published in 1976 by dr. Helen Suzman
with the help of William thetford and
Judas Koch the manuscript was said to be
dictated to her by a voice which claimed
to be Jesus this voice began speaking to
her in the years 1965 to 1972 this is
coming right out of the 60s when you had
all the New Age and Hindu practices
coming into the United States of America
after receiving the first few messages
dr. Susman contacted the daughter of
renowned psychic
Edgar Cayce remember we talked about him
in our second or first message she
contacted the daughter
edgar cayce for advice on what she
should do with the teachings which were
being given to her the series was aired
worldwide by Oprah Winfrey beginning in
January 1 2008 10 years ago Oprah
Winfrey is said to have the largest
church in the world because of her
audience now I'm gonna be careful here
before I go any farther I'm gonna read
some statements that are in that book
that was dictated by this entity that
claim to be Jesus I'm gonna read this
and I'm asking that you will ask the
Lord to help us as we're hearing this
these are all lies of the devil on page
45 it says God is in everything I see on
page 70 it says my mind is part of God's
I am very holy my holiness is my
salvation and my salvation comes from me
page 99 says God does not forgive
because he is never condemned page 10
says a slain Christ has no meaning page
11 through 12 says do not make the
pathetic error of clinging to the old
rugged cross for the journey to the
cross should be the last useless journey
page 13 says the name of Jesus Christ as
such is but a symbol it is a symbol that
is safely used as a replacement for the
many names of all the gods to which you
pray page 15 says the recognition of God
is the recognition of yourself this was
promoted heavily by Oprah Winfrey
heavily now I want
show a video clip and we're gonna take a
look at this it's about two and a half
minutes long and then we'll continue
house quite a show maybe 10,000 people
worshipping celebrating a gentleman
having his own personal experience with
God this is clearly faith in the God in
you your a whisper ation your power God
has so many things to so many people the
warm light of the Sun the sound of sweet
music and in a voice that drives us
forward a friend if you ask me who God
is
I would say there's a bit of the divine
in all of us this garden you its garden
me the God in me is who I really am at
my core the God in me is the best
version of me the God and me is who I
strive to be who I was meant to be
la mejor parte de los habitants el
planeta Selectron crescentus esto
debería prabhakar on dro entre las
reducciones no debemos day Harvey or our
por el Ecolab or our con quien a piensa
distinto confía en buddha creo en Dios
creo que secreto creo en Dios a la
muchos piensan distinto she intended
Tinto bow canarios un quentin agave
River salmon era en esta multitude en
este a bond eco Terra D Sione's alguna
solahart a sake tenemos para todo todo
somos it shows videos
[Music]
creo en el amor creo en el amor creo en
el amor creo en el amor confirm boss
parody foodie repetition death image
Chaldea la voz is 0 & 2 hombres inherits
the diverse religions kanji a fruit of
the paths equal to confer on tour Asia
[Music]
that is startling the first clip that we
just viewed is from a three-hour
documentary where Morgan Freeman goes
around the world and interviews people
of different religious faiths there was
one part in particular that really
shocked me it was when he was doing an
interview with Pastor Joel Osteen and
that was the end and then he came out
and he said God is in everyone
the exact same thing that we're hearing
all these Eastern mystics say and you
think why are we hearing this now and
then you heard earlier where we actually
quoted one of the Japanese masters and
he said there's many paths up Mount Fuji
but there's only one summit love all of
those people said the same thing we
worship different we have different
names for God but we believe in love the
Bible says this is the love of God that
we keep his Commandments and His
commandments are not Grievous this is
how you know who truly loves the Lord
God if they're willing to follow and
obey Him now I want to identify some of
the the New Age gurus that we're seeing
now and we're going to take that into
the emergent church and the spiritual
formation that we're seeing here we have
Oprah Winfrey with three very very
popular guests that are on her show the
first man over to the left his name is
Eckhart Tolle or Eckhart Tolle he is a
strong New Ager has written many books
the man at the top is Tony Robbins this
man is one of the most popular
motivational speakers in the world this
is the type of man I was talking to you
about earlier that came to address those
Esther's in the martial arts circle he
teaches people something that norman
vincent peale did called the power of
positive thinking it's not of God it's
not faith in God's Word
it's faith in self and then right below
that you have Oprah with her show called
Sunday's Super Bowl Sunday and she's
doing an interview with one of the
spiritual formation and emergent church
leaders named Rob el pastor Rob Bell
Eckhart Tolle you'll have to forgive me
because I have got a slide that I forgot
to edit
he said heaven is not a place it's not a
physical place it is a realm of
consciousness he said I am the source of
my own salvation Deepak Chopra founded a
wellness system based on a combination
of Western medicine and era Vedic
principles of health and spirituality
due to his dissatisfaction with the
ability of conventional Western medicine
to help his patients chauffeur's
teachings about the human being and its
wellness are based on Hindu pantheism he
is also a well respected and often Singh
guest on Oprah Show he said thus the
divine pervades the entire universe as
well as human beings and every person
has divinity within himself or herself
Chopra goes on in writes we remain
unfulfilled unless we nurture the seeds
of divinity inside us in reality we are
divinity in disguise and the gods and
goddesses in embryo that are kin
paned within us seek to be fully
materialized he's talking about demons
he's talking about fallen angels this is
a quote that I have heard so many
Christians even of our church repeat to
me we are not human beings having a
spiritual experience we are spiritual
beings having a human experience this
quote comes from a book called Chicken
Soup for the Soul which many Christians
are running out and buying they have no
idea who the quote came from he came
from a man named Pierre Teilhard de
Chardin
he's a Jesuit priest he has also been a
advisor to the UN on spirituality Ellen
White says the warnings of the Word of
God regarding the perils surrounding the
Christian Church belong to us today just
as in the days of the Apostles men tried
by tradition and philosophy to destroy
faith in the scriptures so today by the
pleasing sentiments of higher criticism
evolution spiritualism theosophy and
pantheism the enemy of righteousness is
seeking to lead souls into forbidden
paths this is a book by Brian McLaren
he's a well-known pastor in the emerging
church he's a strong supporter of
spiritual formation the name of the book
is called why did Jesus Moses the Buddha
and Muhammad crossed the road Christian
identity in a multi-faith world what he
just did was he made all of those men
equal he put them all on the same level
today these same teachings are being
suddenly introduced into the Christian
Church this is the University if I
remember correctly that is in Oregon
Biola University they are one of the
strongest proponents of spiritual
formation them and Fox University that
we have a book over here to the left
called
spiritual formation in emerging
adulthood a practical theology for
college and young adult ministry this
book is being promoted even within our
denomination in our universities for
those that are practicing or that have
to take classes in spiritual formation
for a theology major when you go into
those classes the instructor or
professor will give you recommended
reading and you have young adults that
often look up to their professors and
they go and they buy the recommended
reading because they want to do the best
they can when they're in school Acts of
the Apostles page 474 were told to many
the Bible is as a lamp without oil
because they have turned their minds
into channels of speculative belief that
bring misunderstanding and confusion the
work of higher criticism in dissecting
conjecturing reconstructing is
destroying faith in the bible as a
divine revelation it is robbing god's
word of power to control uplift and
inspire human lives I want to pause
there for a moment there's a verse in
Scripture that I would like for you to
look up with me it's 1st Thessalonians
chapter 2 verse 13 the Apostle Paul says
for this cause also thank we God without
ceasing because when you received
the Word of God which you heard from us
you received it not as the word of a man
or the word of men the word of man is
yay nay or maybe I can tell you I'm
gonna be here I can tell my wife I'll be
there to pick you up at five o'clock and
there's a traffic accident they have the
interstate closed off I cannot find a
way around and I show up at seven
o'clock and she says honey what happened
to you and I'm like there I couldn't do
anything I was stuck on a four-lane
interstate I had no way to get around it
I'm meant to be there but I can't
guarantee it Paul says when you receive
the Word of God which you heard from us
you didn't receive it as the word of men
yay nay or maybe but you received it as
it is in truth in Verity the Word of God
the word of deity which effectually
worketh also in you that believe by
spiritualism multitudes are taught to
believe that desire is the highest law
that license means liberty and that man
is accountable only to himself now we
want to look at some quotes from some
very well-known emergent church and
spiritual formation teachers and leaders
Brian McLaren well-known pastor he said
the Bible is not considered an accurate
absolute authoritative or authoritarian
source but a book to be experienced and
one experience can be as valid as any
other can experience dialog feelings and
conversations are equated with Scripture
while Sir
authority and doctrine are to be issued
or disdained he doesn't want of thus
saith the Lord he says this is just
supposed to be something that you read
and you discuss and you talk about it
but you can't depend on this as being
absolutely right or wrong he says no
doctrines are to be absolute and truth
or doctrine must be considered only with
personal experiences traditions
historical leaders etc the Bible is not
an answered book this is a pastor you
want to see why people are having a form
of godliness but no power and that goes
even in our church Marcus Borg
he said seminary also introduced me to
the historical study of Jesus that means
the higher criticism or critical looking
at Jesus from a secular historical
standpoint and of Christian origins I
learned from my professors and the
readings they assigned me that Jesus
almost certainly was not born of a
virgin he did not think of himself as
the Son of God and he did not see his
purpose as dying for the sins of the
world this is exactly what we read from
the people in the 1800s this is what
Thomas Jefferson wrote the Jefferson
Bible Jesus was not born of a virgin
that's per Occulus board goes on and
says I also found the claim when I was
in seminary that Jesus and Christianity
were the only way of salvation to be
troublesome he was bothered by that
pastor Robb Bell now from way back when
our ancestors understood that there's
something dove
vine about our breath they believed
there's something sacred and holy about
the very act of breathing and then he
goes on in this sermon that he gave in
2005 he says central to the Christian
tradition for thousands of years have
been disciplines of meditation
reflection silence and breathing that's
never been part of the Christian
religion that's been part of Roman
Catholicism and paganism and he says the
yoga masters say this is how it is when
you follow Jesus and surrender to God
and then he ends with a quote that is
scary he says I wonder sometimes when we
feel as though God is far god is
thinking I gave you breathing I can't
get closer than that us breathing is not
God it's a gift that God gives us to be
able to breathe that oxygen in pastor
Tony Campolo says mysticism provides
some hope for common ground between
Christianity and Islam and I'm not going
to go into this because I could spend
two hours on that I know right now
within our church we're seeing just like
all the other Protestant churches we're
seeing a very strong push to
indoctrinate people and introduce people
to the idea that allah and jehovah are
the same god they are not when you look
at their character and when you read the
quran the quran says allah cannot have a
son it's impossible and the Bible says
whoever denies the father and the son is
Antichrist
I don't believe Islam is Antichrist I
believe that the daughter of Antichrist
he says both religions Christianity and
Islam have within their histories exam
of a static or esoteric union with God
which seemed at odds with their own
spiritual traditions but have much in
common with each other I do not know
what to make of the Muslim mystics
especially those who have come to be
known as the Sufis what do they
experience in their mystical experiences
could they have encountered the same God
we do in our Christian mysticism pastor
Allen Jones says the image of the Child
Jesus sitting on the Buddha's lap
appeals to me and captures the spirit of
my book called reimaging Christianity or
reimagining Christianity it is an image
of the kingdom the kingdom is a sort of
shorthand signifying an inclusive
community of faith love and social
justice
this is Roman Catholicism but he says I
can picture in my mind Jesus sitting on
the Buddhist lap the son of Almighty God
and yet people are buying his books even
within our church Brian McLaren in his
book a generous orthodoxy says I don't
believe in making disciples must equal
making adherents to the Christian
religion it may be advisable in many
circumstances to help people become
followers of Jesus and yet remain within
their Buddhist Hindu and Jewish context
Buddhists who feel so-called will become
Buddhist followers of Jesus and they
should be given that opportunity and
invitation how
how do you follow Christ Jesus and yet
participate in things that he came to
set us free and save us from Pastor Rick
Warren he said almost the same identical
thing you can keep your own religion
Buddhism Islam Hinduism Mormonism you
just need to add Jesus to the equation
then you become complete you become a
Buddhist with Jesus
a Hindu with Jesus a Muslim with Jesus
and so on you can even throw out the
term Christianity and still be a
follower of Jesus in fact you can throw
out the term Christian too because in
some countries you could be persecuted
for calling yourself a Christian and
there is no need for that just ask Jesus
into your heart you don't have to
identify yourself as a Christian jesus
said whosoever is ashamed of me and my
words I will be ashamed of them the book
that this man wrote that took the world
by storm The Purpose Driven Life and you
would not believe how many seventh-day
Adventist Christians have read or are
reading the book and they don't know
they have no idea great controversy page
561 except those who are kept by the
power of God through faith in his word
the whole world will be swept into the
ranks of this delusion the people are
fast being lulled into a fatal security
to be awakened only by the outpouring of
the wrath of God
that fatal security is you thinking or
someone thinking I don't really have to
surrender my whole heart to God I'm
always gonna be in sin until Christ
returns there's no way you can be
perfect there's no way that you can live
a life victorious over every sin I ask
people when they call I say I used to
drink a lot of alcohol I'm not I used to
drink a lot of alcohol I don't drink
anymore I haven't had a drop of alcohol
since I was 22 years old if God gave me
victory over that can he not give me
victory over every other sin the Bible
says we limit the Holy One of Israel
Ellen White says we expect the Mayoress
of showers of blessing that's why we
receive so little she said if we would
ask for the fullness of the divine
presence we would receive it the Bible
says of Christ's fullness we have
received we are joint heirs with him in
whom dwells the fullness of the Godhead
bodily that means we can lay hold on
Christ and as we surrender every room of
his temple to him he will fill the house
with his glory Christ says through the
Prophet Malachi behold I will send my
messenger and he shall prepare the way
or the path before me and the Lord the
sovereign king whom you are seeking
shall suddenly come to his temple even
the messenger of the Covenant in whom he
delight behold he shall come saith the
Lord of hosts
but who may abide the day of his coming
and who shall stand when he appears for
he is like a refiners fire and like
Fuller's soap and he shall purify the
sons of Levi and he will purge them as
gold and silver so that they and we may
offer unto the Lord and offering in
righteousness do you know the Bible says
that we are to present our bodies as a
living sacrifice God wants us to offer
an offering to him in holiness in
innocence and imperfection and what we
struggle with so often is how can I do
this how is it possible for me to do
this I want to read something to you
turn with me to Micah chapter 7 this
verse has become I read this almost
every single day because this one verse
and its companion verse and Luke say so
much Micah chapter 7 verse 18 through 20
listen to what the Lord says here he
says who is a god and the word God there
in group in Hebrew is Elohim do you know
what the word Elohim means the mighty
one or the mighty ones when we say God
it literally is telling us I am able to
do exceeding abundantly above everything
you can ask or imagine who is a God like
unto thee that pardons iniquity that
passes by the transgression of the
remnant of his heritage the word
iniquity here in Hebrew means perversity
and mischief the word transgression
means rebellion and apostasy
people will tell me I think I've gone
too far
I don't think God can forgive me for
this one this was too big I'm like right
here he says and he says it in the
Exodus chapter 33
I forgive iniquity and transgression and
sin iniquity is perversity and mischief
it means perversity not just moral
perversity but it means it's a perverse
arrow if I have a straight arrow I know
when I shoot it it's gonna hit the mark
but if that arrow has got a little crook
in it it'll never hit the mark it's
almost like when you go to the fair and
they have one of those mirrors that's
got curves in it and you you know what
you look like you look at the regular
mirror and you go that's me and then you
step over in front of the other one and
you go oh wow it makes you look like
you're this wide and this tall that's
perverse it's not the perfect it's not
the way it was designed it says who is a
God like unto thee that pardons iniquity
and he passes by or passes over the
transgression the rebellion and apostasy
of the remnant of his heritage he retain
a--the note is anger forever because he
delights in mercy he delights it means
he goes I can't wait to show what I'm
gonna do in this person's life and I'm
gonna do it because they don't deserve
it
and they're helpless without me he will
turn again it means he had his back
turned to us because he was ashamed of
what we were doing he will turn again he
will have compassion upon us he will if
you want to know what the will of God is
find a place where he says he will do
something that's his will he will subdue
your and my iniquities and thou wilt
cast all of our sins and
the depths of the sea now listen to this
thou will perform thy truth to Jacob
what did what did Christ tell Jacob I'm
gonna change your name Jacob means a
swindler somebody who who trips the guy
in front of them so they can win the
race Christ said I'm changing your name
it will no longer be jacob but israel
that means one who is victorious thou
wilt perform thy truth to Jacob and thy
mercy to Abraham which thou has sworn to
our fathers from the days of old
he made an oath he swear that he would
do this
now turn with me to Luke chapter one and
let me show you where he fulfilled it
Luke chapter 1 verse 67 through 75 and
I'm going to just highlight these verses
this was John the Baptist Father
speaking under inspiration of the Spirit
of God he says blessed be or praise be
the Lord God of Israel for he has
visited and redeemed his people and hath
hath beans past tense right hath is not
I'm gonna do it sometime in the future
he hath raised up a horn a mighty one of
salvation for us in the house of his
servant David as he spake by the mouth
of his holy prophets which have been
since the world began that we should be
saved from our enemies and from the hand
of all that hate us to perform the mercy
which he promised to our fathers and to
remember his holy Covenant covenant
means an oath it's not a contract it's
not an agreement
it's an oath and he says that in verse
73 to remember his holy Covenant
the oath which he sware to our father
Abraham that he would grant unto us let
me ask you a question what's the
difference between a school loan and a
grant a school loan you've got to pay
back I mean people get school loans and
they're paying them back sometimes for
ten years a grant there's no pay back
necessary God knew what he was doing
when he inspired this book to be written
that he would grant unto us that we
being delivered out of the hand of our
enemies might serve him without fear it
doesn't say that you've got to get free
and then God will accept you it says God
sets you free so that you then can serve
him without fear in holiness and
righteousness before him all the days of
our lives
amen hallelujah we're trying to do it
the other way around if I can just clean
my act up God will accept me and maybe
he'll give me his spirit Ellen White
says without the Holy Spirit you can't
do anything but sin she said not even
for one moment she said we cannot keep
ourselves from sinning even for one
moment without Christ and his spirit
that's inspiring
and I want to tell you something i'm i
dont preach cheap grace it's free but it
costs your life as we surrender the
promise is yay and amen it's guaranteed
because he cannot lie and they shall be
mine saith the lord of hosts in that day
when I make up my jewels you remember
the New Jerusalem it
talked about the foundation all those
beautiful jewels that it was made out of
and you remember the walls of Jerusalem
they were as clear as Jasper and they
were a hundred and forty-four cubits
high
that's the hundred and forty-four
thousand that New Jerusalem is a picture
of us
yes I've know it's a real building but
it also is a symbol of us as God's
people he says in that day I will make
up my jewels and I will spare them as a
man spareth his own son that serveth him
then shall ye return and discern between
the righteous and the wicked yay between
him that serveth God and him that
serveth him not and I saw another angel
come down from heaven having great power
and the earth was lightened with his
glory you know this world is in darkness
right now they are waiting to hear good
news they don't just need another set of
facts to to add to their collection they
need glad tidings and that's what Christ
came to share and this angel cried
mightily with a strong voice saying come
out of her my people that you be not
partakers of her sins and that you
receive not of her plagues
for her sins have reached unto heaven
and God has remembered her iniquities
the other night we talked about that in
the promise of the new covenant God said
your sins and iniquities will I remember
no more I want you to do something go
home and get your Strong's Concordance
out or if you have a sword on your
computer it's a free program I encourage
everybody to use it look up that word
remembered he says it in Micah he says
in Psalms 130 or dath our dust
org iniquities who should stand but
there is forgiveness with thee that thou
may us be feared look those words up do
you know what the word remembered means
it means to mark down and keep record of
when you ask Christ to forgive you it's
gone he takes that sin upon himself and
he died and took that to the grave 2,000
years ago
it will never be brought back to you
again people tell me yeah but those
books of record kept in heaven let me
ask you a question
how many sins do you have to commit to
deserve death one Jesus doesn't have to
keep a huge book of every sin you've
committed and confessed and repented of
all you got to do is let go of him and
you're gonna sin within the hour
that's all it takes for you to be lost
he says your sins and iniquities will I
remember no more we are standing upon
the threshold of great and solemn events
prophecies are fulfilling strange
eventful history is being recorded in
the books of heaven everything in our
world is an agitation there are wars and
rumors of wars the nations are angry and
the time of the dead has come that they
should be judged I'm not negating what
we know about the judgment but I want to
add something to that do you remember
where Jesus said let the dead bury their
dead how does a dead person bury
somebody else they were spiritually dead
right that's what Jesus was saying they
don't know me they don't accept me
they're as good as dead they're living
on death row Paul tells us we have
the sentence of death in ourselves from
the day we were born we were born on
death row he says but we were done that
way so that we would not trust in
ourselves but in God that raiseth the
dead
the time of the dead has come that they
should be judged who do the plagues fall
upon those that have not Christ they are
spiritually dead you have judgment that
is passed on somebody and they go to the
tank solitary confinement maybe a man
murdered a bunch of people solitary
confinement the day comes where judgment
has to be executed that's the seven last
plagues only a moment of time as it were
remains in this time of prevailing
iniquity we may know that the last great
crisis is at hand transgression has
almost reached its limit confusion fills
the world and a great terror is soon to
come upon human beings this is not just
talking about the second coming of
Christ the end is very near we who know
the truth that means the unfailing
Verity of Christ's word should be
preparing for what is soon to break upon
the world as an overwhelming surprise
that overwhelming surprise the Apostle
Paul talks about in 2nd Thessalonians
I'm gonna read a verse to to you from
there
2nd Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 4 it's
talking here about the man of sin it
says who opposeth and exalteth himself
above all that is called God or
that is worshipped so that he as God
sitteth in the temple of God showing
himself that He is God and then Paul
says for the mystery of iniquity doth
already work and he talks about this
mystery of iniquity that there is going
to be a man that will actually be filled
with the spirit of Satan Satan I believe
will literally take possession of a
human being and I believe a day will
come when he will be unmasked and do you
know what the world will say when they
see when they see him unmasked and
there's this brilliance and glory
they're gonna say man has become a god
and we're gonna show that's exactly what
the occult and Eastern mysticism are all
striving for for man to reach that point
of godhood it says even him whose coming
is after the working of Satan with all
power and signs and lying wonders I
believe that that man of sin we have in
the Vatican right now beyond a shadow of
a doubt and I believe the day is going
to come when like revelation says he'll
be unmasked and it says that those that
have followed him are going to turn on
him right now what what is coming Ellen
White said this would be an overwhelming
surprise she said we are not to even go
look she said it will be the
overmastering delusion if you even turn
the television on to see what he looks
like it'll be
more than what a mortal can explain away
[Music]